un des plus drôles du monde de france et
même de nava taille des enfants raid
pardon et des enfants mène sa
connaissance tomber comme ça ma vie ou
pour un non
1 c'est plus le fait plus d'enfants
c'est quoi il n'y a pas de cap annoncé
c'est le sommet qu'elle utilise monde tu
as des enfants ait quoi que tu as sorti
un dossier d'ailleurs les enfants sont
là ce soit à non mais je sais pas j'ai
une fille voilà bah on lui fait un bisou
à bord plaisir ah oui allô traboules
hotchkiss yamaki siens non c'est pas si
vous voyez sans enfant ouais je suis
votre fils sur twitter depuis ce
week-end un bon ouais c'est vrai je suis
tombé par hasard sur lui chez le
week-end où il est payé dimanche en toi
monfils à bercy